Oh Dark Phoenix man yeah I'm very late
to the party on this one because
actually didn't come to my theater
that's near me during the summer and I
can't say I blame them I had no
expectation that this was going to be
good so if you want to say that I went
in biased mm-hmm yeah maybe but I was
hoping it would be bad in interesting
ways and it kind of is which at least
makes it more enjoyable than apocalypse
was I'm not sure I can say it's a better
movie then apocalypse was but again at
least it's bad in interesting ways
whereas apocalypse was just so
aggressively mediocre and I am boring
that you know I did I would watch this
again before I'd watch apocalypse not
that I think I'm ever gonna watch this
again either oh and in case anyone's
wondering why'd you watch this thing
when you missed it and seemed to have
dodged a bullet and didn't think you'd
like it anyway well it's because I'd
like to do a ranking of the Fox x-men
films and I can't until I've seen all of
them so it's kind of obligatory all
right Dark Phoenix Fox's second crack at
this story after folding it in to be
about ow a third of the plot to x-men
The Last Stand which I am a little bit
of an apologist for not a massive one
but a little bit it's one of those
movies a bit like Batman Forever that I
say or the Ben Affleck daredevil I'm not
gonna say that it's good but it's better
than most people give it credit for
that's kind of my feeling on X
Last Stand and they thought they should
take another crack at it this movie's
weird and not for like any kind of
trippy mind but it's not it's not like
with Legion weird if you want like
proper weird x-men go watch Legion but
like this is weird in just it's just odd
so like now granted some what I'm about
to say may have been properly set up in
Apocalypse I don't remember it being am
I looking at the synopsis of apocalypse
didn't made it seem like it wasn't but I
could also be wrong about this because I
refuse to go back and watch apocalypse
again to find out whether or not I'm
right about this but this makes some
serious leaps versus apocalypse and it
it feels like it's actually the sequel
to a movie that didn't happen this
doesn't feel like a sequel to apocalypse
it feels like there's a movie missing
there's actually a problem I've been
having with sequels a bit lately and I
feel like we're skipping movies and they
they bring out films that look like
they're paying off or are trying to
invert stuff that wasn't properly set up
and we didn't see or didn't have for
long enough so like this whole movie is
supposed to be about the breakdown of
the x-men except this specific team of
the x-men weren't even a team until the
literal last few minutes of the previous
movie so when you go into the next movie
and start pulling them apart well there
isn't uh there's a lot of weight to that
because we haven't seen them be a team
not really not any meaningful way I feel
like that's the kind of middle movie I
think that we're so often missing in
these things because it's like bring
everybody together next move we split
everybody apart like you do
at least one where they function cuz
otherwise it's like oh well then coming
together just didn't work did it because
they if they fell apart immediately now
you'll want to be technical in universe
there's a nine year jump between the
previous film and this one for no reason
that I can think whatsoever other than
it's become part of the X film gimmick
and I don't know why
so first class was in the sixties
Days of Future past was in the 70s
Apocalypse was in the 80s so this one
decided it had to be in the 90s even
though there's no reason it needs to be
like narrative Lee there is no benefit
to leaping it forward again I think nine
years they just do it because that's the
thing that these movies just do now I
guess why I don't know and I guess I
because there's a nine-year gap they
feel justified in acting like all this
development and progress and progress
and character relations have formed and
and everything is like oh well that
would have happened over nine years like
yeah but it doesn't matter cuz we
haven't seen it like since what is the
president calling Charles Xavier
to help sort out emergencies I I'm sorry
what and you know they try and have
Scott and Jean which really only just
barely got started and then okay Jean
Jean and the whole Phoenix thing they
couldn't decide what they were doing
because they set it up as if they were
doing it the same way x-men Last Stand
did it which was this was always inside
of her but Charles had like helped keep
it in check by messing with her mind but
they then they also in addition to that
which is set up from the get-go they
also bring in the space Firebird Phoenix
force thing that takes jean over why are
you doing both
there is no reason to do both and I know
that if you want to be technical about
it the comics did both but they didn't
do both at the same time they did
originally the Dark Phoenix saga saga
which still holds up still a good piece
of work if you haven't read it Chris
Claremont is the freaking man so like it
still holds up what that was was gene
losing control of her power and becoming
such a massive fact that it ultimately
ends in her death because it has to now
later they basically retcon it with this
whole thing of the Phoenix force but
within the narrative of the story being
told it was originally just her power
was too much and then later on it became
the space Firebird thing and they didn't
do both simultaneously because the two
are tripping over each other because
they both accomplish the same thing
either she has this power already that
she can't control or she's taken over by
this other force these both serve the
exact same function they're redundant
you don't do both of them at the same
time yet this does why and it brings
back character like why is magneto back
again like I didn't know why magneto was
back in Apocalypse I don't know what
he's back here and they completely
repeat like almost note for note
his entire thing here that was in
Apocalypse and the one thing that was in
Apocalypse was already a lukewarm
retread of his original motivations so
at this point he's on Genosha and
basically running mutant commune and he
doesn't want to fight until one of his
little until somebody cares about dies
and then he puts the helmet on and goes
fighting again and you know
but that would have had some weight to
it if he hadn't done that last movie
last movie he wanted to be peaceful he
he changed his ways people he cared
about died he puts the helmet back on in
wreck shop you literally just did this
there is no weight to the idea that he's
ever gonna stop because he's never
stopped oh man
and it's just so clunky though he goes
from point to point it like you could
practically see Jennifer Lawrence's
relief when spoilers does anyone care
mystique dies your bases here go to do
this anymore and I I did actually say
this out loud I'm watching the movie and
at the very end went spoiler gene dies I
think if Scott says or maybe his hangs
as she's gone and Charles goes no she's
free and I actually said I loud from
from her contract oh god I feel so bad
that these people have to come in and do
this it's it is so miss shapen and just
it's just none of it fits together it's
it's this weird mutation of a film that
you just look at it and go why is that
there why would you do that why is there
this and this and oh my god and now two
x-men movies in a row manage to take an
actor who I've previously never seen
give a bad performance and stick them in
a role where they cannot possibly give a
good performance last time it was Oscar
Isaac as Apocalypse this time it's
Jessica Chastain as I [ __ ] something
like that I don't even I don't even know
they just weird alien things that they
try to be it like
build it like it's a big deal and
someone even has a lines they're not
mutants like yeah but their abilities
are not that far off from what we see
mutants do so that's supposed to make it
scary because it doesn't and like if
gene herself is the threat why do we
need the aliens here they're not putting
her on trial for being too powerful Mia
threat to the universe the way that they
did in the original story they just want
the power for themselves which means
that the threat posed by them if they
get it is the exact same threat
already posed by gene who has it again
it's redundant both these things
accomplish the exact same thing why and
it doesn't matter nothing matters
because Disney has x-men back so like
this is the this is definitively the end
of Oh
like I said this is a musingly bad this
is bad made in ways that you go I'm
sorry what as opposed to apocalypse
which was so completely predictable it
just made you go is it over yet
where is this like I find this amusingly
bad it's not I'm not gonna use the
phrase too bad it's good but I laughed I
also didn't pay a lot of attention to it
I'd like I mentally checked out very
very early into this thing yeah just
what a waste but always the time and
resources and people like everybody
involved had better things to do and in
most of the performances you can tell
the actors knew they had better things
to do I'm pretty sure all of them as
soon as I got called or on their phones
to their agents how many more days do I
love to shoot on this and when can I get
on to something else
what a mess Dark Phoenix using it
all right what do you think about it
whatever your thoughts are drop
something on the comments let's talk
about a bunch of stuff to do down there
as well like and subscribe
it is a help to me also I have a patreon
link down below that is even more help
for me even a dollar a month is greatly
appreciated helps me cover my bills and
there's other links besides click on
them they'll take your places oh don't
get Arnav to because at the end of the
day you're the council
I'm just running the meetings and until
next time this council is adjourned
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]